So next game against im Fun Impe is
n't exactly my favorite opponent because he
plays so unpleasantly. Opening is so unpleasant and
I don't really know how to
get a position that I like back then. There's
also a German player
Christian Troyke
who stupidly plays some things in a
similar way to me
So yes, I've had this strange setup
against him several times
where I actually, um,
if I can imagine that the
reprimand is so outstandingly good, but
no, he always gets along with this one, he
somehow copes with this position quite well,
so now he wants bishop has six
games  yes, that's now
changed to symmetrical English
I don't know maybe knight F5
but then maybe bishop gif 5 is
a bit uncomfortable yes good but I
want to prevent spoon 6 for now it
seems like I want to play e-4 I do
n't know either well I'm getting ready  Here in the
Shadow
maybe I have
a serious problem here, congratulations, there it is,
the problem.
I don't know if it's really a
problem, but in any case it
seems like a move that
perhaps you should have reacted to somehow
good, okay, I ca
n't build any more, play less, so
now the i4 does it,
yes, I just have something like that, it's
not well coordinated, no, so
that the eight EF runs and then
some knight move will probably come, no,
it's that bad, I don't know, yes,
interesting,
well, I  Of course, I can always
take it here and say that
I don't care about the source because then the runner is
more important, yes,
I do that now before I
think about a wolf here,
so very often the many shetto
runners are already
valuable ones  Figures
and I then really have options
maybe on the white squares
so directly with him when he takes there
bishop has three or so okay now
he first makes
that understandable
because he would like to swap that too
no that's clear
yes  If I now play Tommy 8 games
then he swapped a sound park and
so the position is actually not
nice if you sacrificed the quality
I have an alternative here
somehow
no, I don't like doing it that way either
but
so then I'll just take it here  The
endgame with a pawn for the
quality
is not what you want but
is definitely difficult to
exploit for white. I would say
the rooks don't have any
real squares here yet
and this constellation is just not
easy so that he is completely here now  to
move forward quickly with G4 and
everything, that will take a while here,
so now he can't move
forward at all,
so I just always have to make sure that I
have G4 under control here. The question is whether I
somehow prefer something here or not  I'm
really just standing in the position I'm
just standing so b8c8 or something like that
I can yes I can play the
games
yes he can of course he can
try it but the doubling does
n't do that much. The question now is
whether C4 C3 is an idea  I mean,
I don't actually want to
open the position, but
when I get to it,
of course he also has a weak a-pawn
and F3 is possibly also weak, yes, do
that,
yes, it still seems very compact
for Black. Actually, it doesn't seem as if  You're going to get into
a lot of
trouble now that you're in the position you
can't do, you ca
n't fool yourself, but
now he's on the seventh row, but it
's not that
bad,
the whole structure covers
each other,
yes  you could run around with the king, yes,
that's of course right,
so I'm standing up now. I don't
know if that's a good decision,
so on B5 A6 and then Thomas 4,
he can even now make the tone
that unpleasant,
no, that's stupid because now  I do
n't have it myself Thomas 4
I probably didn't defend that well
yes yes it works now too yes
I have something bad A6 B5 Man
and boy did I disconnect the tower here myself
after Tom C4 he didn't see it okay
he wants both  bring it to the eighth
row, which isn't exactly a
bad thing,
yes, there's still time and position lost,
probably
yes, I think you still had
good remy chances in the
endgame, probably maybe
I really played too passively here
or the resolution C5 with that  c-pawn
wasn't good, it could also be very
bad. In any case, here was the
idea with B5, so
that was kind of bad,
but he's already talked about progress,
no, he can get to B4 with the king,
that's not so pleasant,
yes, maybe you have to  Here we really
stand by the C8 B8 until the
next day, he can't
do so much now,
yes it
probably would have been better